[Music]  one of my favorite things about watching  the Olympics is all the super slow  motion video they use for the instant  replays if the technology is so good  absolutely with the slow-mo and it's  really incredible it makes every moment  look so much cooler so I loved it so  much I decided to rent the same  expensive high-speed cameras they use  for the Olympics and see if we could  create our own slow-motion moments right  here yeah and we were a little bit  rushed but here's what we came up with  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  for more thrilling slow-motion moments  visit team koco.com slash slow-mo if you  weren't sated by spider-man throwing up  and you need more get on your computer  right now please all right I got an  amazing show tonight